what's going on guys it's January which
means it's time once again for the
screen 'is the award show that you know
and love join us as we celebrate the
best and worst movies and TV had to
offer in 2016 now let's see who the
winners and losers are in a bunch of
categories we just thought of right
before we started shooting with first up
what do Z right off the bat the highly
coveted biggest comeback award for the
person or thing who made the biggest
comeback in 2016 the nominees Winona
Ryder r-rated movie musical and the
winner Oh Jay Simpson that's right the
juice actually had the best TV show the
People vs Jay Simpson and the best
documentary man that eight hour long Oh
Jay made in America was fantastic the
juice is loose once again but actually
very much still locked up Oh Jay feel
free to come pick up your award which is
a bottle of mark 7 ironman cologne if
you make parole later this year come on
by and get it you know what ii thought
we'll mail it to you next up is the f it
I'm out award and the winner is Leonardo
DiCaprio for winning that coveted Oscar
in February then doing nothing the
entire year aside from cruising around
on yachts would model Congrats leo the
only goal you've left yourself to
accomplish is saving the entire planet
I'm sure you will get that done soon I
mean it's got to be easier than eating
that raw bison liver that you ate in the
revenant mmm gross this next award is
one of my favorite the mainstream movie
that sounds like a porno award and the
nominees are bad mom sausage party me
before you dirty grandpa the infiltrator
risen max steel and the winner is
tweener
yes 2016 s documentary of dong texting
former Congressman Anthony Weiner was so
compelling couldn't stop watching it I
just can't get it up Weiner Congrats
Weiner you ad yet
another award to your shelf your sleazy
dirty scandal-ridden shelf next up is
the jumped the shark award for the TV
show that definitively jumped the shark
and 2016 the nominees are mr. robot
Modern Family's perennial favorite the
Simpsons as the winner is the walking
dead
first and angered fans with a slain
cliffhanger ending then made us wait a
whole summer to find out what we already
knew it was Glenn then rewarded us with
a slow-ass season two voted mainly to
secondary characters roaming around
aimlessly and negan mugging for the
camera with his dumb bat you know what
your thought maybe it's time for you to
join Shane and Merle and that one lady
and that old grandpa guy and Laurie and
Frank Darabont up in that big Alexandria
and the sky just thought I know you
won't do it see you for ten more seasons
Walking Dead next we have the lifetime
suck Cheeseman award series is there a
prestigious award given for a consistent
legacy of sucking and the winner is
video game movies this was the year
gamer movies were supposed to go legit
but Warcraft and Assassin's Creed both
proved that even big budgets great
directors talented actors and a solid
premise still can't make video game
movies good game over
hang it up okay don't log on delete your
account no video game movie will ever be
good except maybe Bioshock that could be
cool or modern warfare
maybe halo I'd like to see a Last of Us
moving wait a second that's how they
keep getting made isn't it I'm out video
game movies and until the next one
next up is the award for most overused
trailer trope and the winner is haunting
covers of pop songs they were literally
everywhere this year from Power Rangers
I keep a close watch on a kind of mine
to Blair Witch hell or high water bed
shop named ghost in the shell
transformers five fifty shades darker
you got me
[Music]
and a cure for wellness
oh listen this worked great for the
social network seven years ago enough a
cover version of a 15 year old Flaming
Lips song will never convince me that
transformers vibe will be good only a
lobotomy could convince me that
transformers 5 will be good
our next award this one's a doozy the
who wanted this award the nominees are
Independence Day to the Huntsman to
Alice in Wonderland
- and the winner fuller house hey here's
an idea let's revive a dated 90s sitcom
that was already just so campy and
terrible to watch ditch most of the cast
that you know and love for the bulk of
the show not even the Olsen twins and
then make a 2016 sitcom that's even
worse
brilliant here we go with a hotly
contested award the best superhero award
the nominees are
Deadpool Batman Doctor Strange Wonder
Woman and the winner stranger thing true
no one on this show is an actual
superhero but stranger things
single-handedly rescued the summer of
2016 from being a worthless trash pile
of disappointing movie Congrats stranger
things you did justice to everything
that's good in this world except barb
ah right people are uh-oh hashtag cringe
alert it's the most Awkward celebrity
encounter award surprisingly I'm not
nominated for any of my weird
disconcerting interviews I've done the
nominees are
this French TV presenter dissing Jonah
Hill how do I put to you get PA watch
kids
I'm just rude am i right
this painfully awkward monosyllabic
Jerry Lewis Hollywood Reporter interview
have you ever thought about retiring why
it was there never a moment that you
thought it might be time to retire you
would why Duncan Jones deftly handling
this angry journalist slashed a Warcraft
enthusiast will you the white man to run
the script but the wrong man to make the
film I've been reinforced in my belief
that that's the case by the incredible
feedback I've had some fan yes thank you
okay and the winner is sad Ben Affleck
Congrats Ben your Batman was the best
part of Batman V Superman and you're sad
sad introspection was the best part of
pretty much any year ever by the way did
Ben and Casey Affleck do a Freaky Friday
body switch or something cuz Ben is
struggling with a string of bad reviews
and Casey seems to be on the cusp of
Oscar gold somebody searched the Affleck
household for a monkey saw am i right
those monkey paws are filled with curses
Oh
next up is a classic screaming the Anna
Kendrick award given to the celebrity
you didn't know you were attracted to
but then all of a sudden you were like
oh hey I totally do that person 2016
vana Kendrick award goes to Ryan
Reynolds sexy yes charisma he's got it
to spare but let's be honest before 2016
we only thought about three things when
we saw Ryan Reynolds lame Deadpool
lame Green Lantern and is he Brian
Gosling now one franchise revival later
he's the toast of the town
he even did an honest trailer Congrats
Ryan Reynolds you were always cute but
now I totally celebrate International
Women's Day with you
this is one of my favorites the worst
rick flagg line from Suicide Squad the
nominees are we've got to cut her heart
out we've got a gutter heart out
Here Come Slipknot the man who can climb
anything Here Come Slipknot the man can
climb anything and the winner is you
know what I'll just let rick flagg take
it
this is katana you got my back I would
advise not getting killed by her her
sword traps the souls of the victim wow
that exposition was so on the nose
it made Christopher Nolan jealous and
now I've made both a suicide squad joke
and a Christopher Nolan joke in the same
category please be gentle in the
comments section this next award is e
please stop talking the award and the
winner Mary Elizabeth Winstead first she
had to put up with Thuy stalker Michael
Cera and Scott Pilgrim vs. the world but
in 2015 she was stalked by both creepy
John Goodman and 10 Cloverfield Lane and
Paul Dano and dead Harry Potter and
Swiss Re man leave the floor woman alone
moving right along our next screen E is
the Posey reward or poser Award or the
movie you will most likely pretend to
have seen without actually seeing it
nominees the very long fences Lawrence
foster Jenkin Terrence Malick's knight
of cups very sad but very good
manchester by the sea and the winner
stylin yes a nearly 3:00 hour Martin
Scorsese film about Jesuit priest sounds
like something you should see and I said
almost none of you've seen it but if you
need to fake it just a reminder it's not
about the Mafia none of Liam Neeson's
relatives have been taken atom drivers
also in it and most importantly it's not
Andrew Garfield's other religious themed
Oscar bait movie hacksaw ridge good luck
out there pretending you thought silence
if you lie about it and fool someone
tell us in the comments section below
and now as always we'd like to close out
the show by remembering the people and
things that we said goodbye to in 20
Dean here's our in memoriam
[Music]
your movie not know that
you feel bad your fall we all want our
my
you feel bad don't just fall be Almighty
that's another streamys in the books
what you think what we leave out yeah
many cool categories for us were there
any nominees that we whipped on let us
know in the comment section below I want
to thank you for watching screen junkies
for a great 2016 it was fun talking to
yeses let's do some more of it
I'm how Rudnick's hit me up on Twitter
thanks for watching bye bye hey guys did
you know that this end card works with
your phone now I know right click the
boxes below to watch more screen junkies
videos and click the screen junkies logo
to subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more